beginning aimi starter rolles so when
you start taking iido the ukmi can be a
really challenging thing to overcome at
first starter rolls are a way that you
can ease yourself into the ukmi practice
one of the great starter roll practices
is a rocking
practice in this practice I'm going to
sit on the ground like this Arch my
spine and tuck my
chin I want to always make sure my
Chin's tucked this keep my head well
away from the mat as I go backwards then
all I'm going to do is with the curved
spine roll straight
back and then straight forward at first
this might be hard if you don't have
much core strength and you'll need a
little little momentum so you can go
ahead and KCK your
feet to help you go what's nice about
this is it gets your body used to the
curved position you're going to need to
have when you're taking a roll and also
getting used to tucking your chins
really good from this practice cuz
you're always going to be tucking your
chin to keep your head from
smashing rocking practice I'm
Christopher hind thanks for
watching